t
[Musique]
la légendaire rivière miramichi le roi
de la rivière le saumon de l'atlantique
a fait rêver des pêcheurs de partout sur
la planète
mais la miramichi comme plusieurs autres
rivières du nouveau brunswick n'est plus
ce qu'elle était on le fait il ya dix
ans voyage extraordinaire et de belles
prises tout dernièrement un voyage
beaucoup plus difficiles les changements
climatiques l'agriculture la
déforestation et la présence du bar rayé
sont montrés du doigt on pêchait des
températures d'eau extrêmement chaude
impossible de capturer un sermon il jeu
ça c'est pour les garder quasiment en
ville fait que ce test est quasiment
c'est quasiment attristant faible de
savoir qu'une rivière aussi majestueuse
jabain en jeu
le température d'eau 112 milles
seulement revenez dans la miramichi en
1990 après leur voyage de 2 à 3 ans sur
la côte ouest du groenland en 2019 on
n'en comptait que 15000 le déclin de
l'espèce est dramatique signs mais voilà
une lueur d'espoir le conseil
international pour l'exploration de la
mer basé à copenhague
note pour la première fois depuis des
années une augmentation des prix ce
commercial en 2020 comparativement à
2019 dans les rivières de l'est du
canada ont fait le même constat pour la
pêche récréative
la fédération du saumon atlantique crois
qu'il s'agit des premiers effets d'une
entente signée en 2018 avec les pêcheurs
du groenland en acceptant que les
captures reste sous la barre des 20
tonnes ils obtiennent de l'aide pour
développer une pêche durable l'éco
tourisme et des projets scientifiques
mais à elles seules cette entente ne
réglera pas tout surtout pas l'enjeu du
climat les mairies mac ont décidé de s'y
attaquer une de leurs initiatives en
pierreries les courbes des ruisseau qui
se jette dans la miramichi le nouveau
profil de ce ruisseau empêche l'eau de
ce panier de se réchauffer l'eau froide
se rend plus rapidement vers la rivière
ce qui pourrait permettre de créer des
refuges thermique pour la survie des
poissons l'été
céline dj keating qui sera aux premières
loges pour voir si tous ses efforts
porteront fruit
la jeune femme originaire de miramichi
et maintenant biologiste sur la rivière
qui l'a vu grandir
c'est elle qui recense les populations
de poissons si nombreux pour les jeunes
de sa région
il est très rare d'avoir déjà vu un
saumon sauvage et c'est pour changer ce
constat que les dédie sa carrière ici
mon nom en beau radio canada miramichi